au nord de khar ki ve ca tive cas est
une zone sinistrée
l'artillerie russe pilonnent jour et
nuit ce quartier résidentiel
tous les habitants ont fui
ou presque
quelques irréductibles comme ludmila ont
choisi de rester
ce jour
le 23 mars un missile a frappé son
immeuble
et si vous veniez théorie des
sept familles a fui vers un endroit plus
sûr mais ils passent tous les jours au
quartier par solidarité
les armes coach de dean cessé d'aimer et
vous avons prévu un programme tu vas
t'appeler
[Musique]
ici les plus de bombes rue ce rythme le
quotidien
un gars qui ont déjà fauché trois cents
civils au moins
à
chaque alerte un autre me l'a 75 ans
s'abritent dans cette cave qu'elle
partage avec son voisin sagna
je te coûte
quant à lui dit
tu t'y malik
le mille a été professeur de musique
voilà cinq semaines qu'elle se terre
dans son abri
[Musique]
la vitalité
d'un jeu vous tenait été initié l'été
d'un magnum
enfin une accalmie
le voisin en profite pour nous conduire
au cinquième étage où le missile a
frappé
sagna est d'origine russe
cette guerre entre frères le dépasse
vous admirerez jean toninato
nicollin
j'hallucine à autre chose
sagna habite un étage plus bas sa vie
entière est réduite un tas de gravats sa
fille a fui à l'ouest du pays
ne lui reste plus que les eaux de son
chat tués pendant la frappe
des bulldogs
[Musique]
malgré les bombes ludmila elle aussi
refuse de partir son quartier c'est sa
vie
qm
un chien s'est acheté un à romilly ce il
ya une écoute dans l'écriture il a nié
toute agression
cette fois les tirs proviennent du côté
ukrainien
des combats se poursuivent en périphérie
de kharkiv ces derniers jours l'armée
ukrainienne a annoncé avoir lancé une
contre-offensive et repris plusieurs
localités à quelques kilomètres à l'est
de la ville